in skepticism consciousness truly
experiences itself is internally
contradictory from this experience
emerges a new form of consciousness
which brings together the two thoughts
which scepticism holds apart skepticisms
lack of thought about itself must vanish
because it is in fact one consciousness
which contains within itself these two
modes this new form is therefore one
which knows that it is the dual
consciousness of itself itself
liberating unchangeable and self
identical and as self bewilder against
all perverting and it is the awareness
of this contradictory nature this self
contradictory nature of itself in
stoicism self-consciousness is the
simple freedom of itself in skepticism
this freedom becomes a reality negates
the other side of determinate existence
but really duplicates itself and now
knows itself to be a duality
consequently the duplication which
formerly was divided between two
individuals the lord of the bondsman is
now lodged in one the duplication of
self-consciousness within itself which
is essential in the notion of spirit is
thus here before us but not yet in its
unity the unhappy consciousness is the
consciousness of self as a dude dual
natured merely contradictory being
paragraph 206 is now introducing us to
this new shape of consciousness
what Hegel is going to call the unhappy
consciousness area the wooden glutton
booth was design right and this is going
to occupy working this out much more of
this section of the self consciousness
portion of the work then the skepticism
did or stoicism did or indeed even the
master-slave dialectic or the beginning
part of self-consciousness this is
really the most important part of this
entire portion self-consciousness why
well we're going to see a lot of you
know playing itself out in the later
sections ultimately in the religion
section I don't want to get too far
ahead of ourselves in this paragraph
he's charting a kind of progress that's
taking place he begins by talking about
the contrast between skepticism itself
and this new shape that's happening but
then it's going to bring in stoicism as
well so he starts out saying in
skepticism consciousness experiences
itself is internally contradictory so
that's part of where skepticism was
heading to right he says from this
experience you get a new form of
consciousness which is going to bring
together the two thoughts which
skepticism holds apart so skepticism is
not able to reconcile the connection or
the difference or the contradiction
between these two sides the unhappy
consciousness is going to attempt to do
so over and over and over again by a
whole variety of means that are
be quite interesting to to watch and to
connect with historical phenomenon
so he says skepticisms lack of thought
about itself must vanish
why well skepticism got itself to a
certain point it realizes the
contradiction it realizes even that this
contradiction lies at the nature of
self-consciousness but it doesn't see
any way to get past this so so long as
you stay there you're stuck with
skepticism and you can't move any
further along the dialectic so he says
what's the key thing here it is in fact
one consciousness which contains within
itself these two models you have two
different ways of seeing the same thing
here and that determines whether you
stay at this stage of skepticism or move
to the unhappy consciousness what is the
other happy consciousness bring to the
table the knowledge that this is part of
in the contradictory nature of
consciousness and then that's going to
move further beyond them so he says this
new form is therefore one which knows it
is the dual consciousness of itself
consciousness of itself on this side of
the universal consciousness of itself on
this side as the empirical as who I am
as a actually existing human being what
is what are the attributes of this let's
start actually on this side I know the
text goes first into the the other one
but let's do that so he says this side
is salt the will Turing and itself
perverting that's what the skeptic
realized about their own empirical
consciousness their own who they are so
that doesn't sound very good right now
on this side we have the good stuff
right like beating self liberating
unchangeable self identical so start to
give them any ideas about where we're
heading that's
keep that in mind as we go through this
success we saw in stoicism
well the self-consciousness is a simple
freedom of itself a freedom that's
coming through thought and it gates the
other to the world the line and some
problems with that that are going to
lead into skepticism and skepticism this
freedom he says becomes a reality
it totally manages to negate the other
Society of determinate existence but
then it replicates itself and now knows
itself to be a duality he says
consequently the duplication which was
formerly divided between two individuals
what does he mean they're the
master-slave dialectic in self
consciousness as we saw the you know the
awareness of the two self consciousness
is the struggle for recognition they are
in unequal positions in relation to each
other looks like the Lord the master has
the upper hand for a while it turns out
the slave was the one who's developing
we saw the stoicism just kind of nullify
as that relationship the manner as far
as the stoic is concerned the skeptic is
not really concerned with the
master-slave dialectic per se either but
instead up with with this this
bifurcation that's happening within
consciousness itself kind of being two
people one of whom is a hyper person a
super person and the other one is the
schmuck that we happen to be at any
given time right now he only says the
duplication of self-consciousness within
itself which is essential in the notion
of spirit as why is so important why the
unhappy consciousness is so important
this duplication doesn't just happen in
terms of society and the person who gets
to be charged the person is the
universal and then the rest of us poor
bastards down here who slave away or
work
have to you know going clock in and
their job or do them right it's not just
about say YouTube and us content
providers or pick whatever you like
right it's also happening within every
one of us as a person we contain
multiple aspects each of which has its
own determinate naseeb has its own
dynamism which can conflict with each
other which can take cues from each
other this is a whole understanding of
human being that's being implied here as
well as of society as well as of
historical development the dialectic
spirit itself he says this this duality
is inherent in the notion of spirit
itself so you're not going to you know
heylia's indeed in a certain respect of
moments right there's a totality we're
all part of this grand totality but for
monist he's he's one who's you know sure
den said a lot on showing us duality
within the the monism duality running
through duality through duality to
duality all this splitting all this cell
fathering all of these than connections
that have to be restored at a certain so
he says the duplication of self
consciousness is essential in the notion
of spirit is thus here before but not
yet in its unity for scepticism this
awareness this experience of the duality
is something that anguishes it it's a
problem for the unhappy consciousness it
also is the same it is feeling this as a
kind of anguish as an estrangement as an
emanation but it's also a problem to be
solved because it's aware it makes this
into a central issue it's aware of this
being part of its nature and it's going
to try to overcome this it's
so he says the unhappy consciousness is
the consciousness of self as a dual
natured merely contradictory being now
it's a challenge to try to address
this unhappy inwardly disrupted
consciousness since it's essentially
contradictory nature is for it a single
consciousness must forever have present
in the one consciousness the other also
and thus it is driven out of each and
turn in the very moment when it imagines
it has successfully attained to a
peaceful unity with the other it's true
return into itself or its reconciliation
with itself will however display the
notion of spirit that has become a
living spirit and is achieved in the
actual existence because it already
possesses as an a single undivided
consciousness a dual nature the unhappy
consciousness itself is the gazing of
one self-consciousness into another and
itself is both and the unity of both is
also its essential nature but it is not
as yet explicitly aware that this is its
essential nature or that it is the unity
of both
having introduced the unhappy
consciousness in the previous paragraph
heel is now going to point us towards a
sort of general structure and where
we're hoping to go with the unhappy
consciousness and it's important to keep
in mind the very last sentence the very
last phrase that he's talking about here
where he says that the unhappy
consciousness is not as you explicitly
aware of its essential nature it's it's
aware of how it is in many respects
we'll get to that in just a moment but
it's not aware of its essential nature
or that it is the unity of both modes of
consciousness it's going to engage in a
kind of over and over again forgetting
now at the same time it is aware
although it doesn't have the well worked
out knowledge at each point about this
this splittings disruption as he's
calling it here or everybody is another
word for it
alienation which is occurring within
consciousness itself and also by way of
the projection as we're going to see of
consciousness onto the world onto that
which is beyond the world into something
that will become a kind of God now he
starts out staying in this unhappy
inwardly disrupted consciousness since
it's essentially contradictory nature is
for a single consciousness it is aware
at some level of its its unity it's
aware as a unity that's not aware of
itself as a unity it's aware generally
in an effective way or way using images
rather than conceptually he says it must
forever have present to the one
consciousness the other also and thus it
is driven
I would reach and turn the very moment
when it imagines it is successfully
attained to a peaceful unity with the
other so we have this disruption this
bifurcation is splitting that's taking
place and so the one consciousness the
the essential the unchanging and the
other consciousness the empirical the
contingent the you know self wildered
consciousness each one of them has the
other consciousness in some way within
and there's a back and forth between the
two of them engaging each other that is
supposed to bring about some sort of
unity right and on the trouble is is
that this unity every time that it seems
to happen is also therefore a null
that's like always slipping away like
something that's that's breezy and
you're trying to get a grip on it and if
you keep on pushing it further and
further out of your reach right now
where this is supposed to be going is
toward some sort of reconciliation
toward some sort of thing that's a unity
bubble in unity right he says it's true
returning to itself where it's
reconciliation with itself that's going
to happen wade through the rock towards
the end of the section and indeed not
even be in this section but in other
sections to happen later on he says it
will display the notion of spirit that
has become a living spirit a spirit that
has this duality within itself is yet
not becoming a contradictory conflict
chaos within itself because of that he
says it has achieved an actual existence
because it already possesses as a single
undivided consciousness of dual nature
where we're headed with this is the
grasp that you know things that appear
to be simple and unified have duality
within them as the very nature of the
kind of things that they are including
ourselves including our conscious
we're not yet there he says the unending
consciousness itself is the gazing of
one consciousness into another so each
one of these is each one of these
consciousnesses is something that he has
agency it is something that can even
believe itself to be a separate
consciousness how does this creative
play itself out well we're going to see
that there's going to be a kind of like
a set projection where the one
consciousness gets pushed outside of the
empirical human being and the human
being that gazes into it relates itself
to it and yet there's also this gazing
back which is only possible because it's
the unhappy consciousness that's really
doing all of this if we think about this
in terms of worshipper and God for Hegel
the Gihon is not something totally
separate from us it's going to be
something which is what we are because
we are in this unhappy consciousness we
mistakenly identify ourselves with just
this when actually were both sides of it
like he says the only happy
consciousness itself is both in the
unity we both is also it's essential
nature but it's not yet conscious of
that unity how will it become conscious
that unity that's going to take some
work
since it is to begin with only the
immediate unity of the two and so takes
them to be not the same but opposites
one of them that is the simple
unchangeable it takes to be the
essential being but the other the
protein changeable it takes to be the
unofficial the two are for the unhappy
consciousness alien to one another and
in because is itself the consciousness
of this contradiction it identifies
itself with the changeable consciousness
and takes itself to be the unofficial
being but as consciousness of
unchangeableness where a simple
essential being it must at the same time
set about freeing itself from the
unassembled
that is from itself for though we did
indeed takes itself to be merely the
changeable and the unchangeable is for
hidden alien being yet it is itself a
simple hence unchangeable consciousness
and hence it is aware that this
consciousness is its own essence
although in such a way that again it
does not itself take the essence to be
its own the attitude of the science to
both cannot therefore be one of mutual
indifference that is it cannot be
indifferent towards the unchangeable
rather it is itself directly both of
them and the relation of the two is
great a relation of essential being to
the UH essential so that this ladder has
to be set aside but sense for it both
are equally essential and contradictory
it is merely the contradictory movement
in which one opposite does not come to
rest in its opposite but in it only
produces itself afresh as an opposite
impaired graphically we're now seeing
yet more of the structure of the unhappy
consciousness being laid out and this is
really saying a lot of the same stuff
that we just talked about with the last
paragraph but it's putting a particular
twist on it's becoming a bit more
specific a bit more determinate and it's
coming to an important conclusion at the
end I don't want to skip to the
conclusion we'll come to that in a
moment the conclusion by the way doesn't
really fit into this scheme up quite so
so well that fits more the other stuff
that we're going to talk about so he
says the unhappy consciousness is only
the immediate unity of these two right
the universal consciousness which is
simple unchangeable is essential being
and then the imperial consciousness
contingents of the wildering problematic
all these sorts of things right there's
a splitting that's taking place between
the two of these all right so that each
of them has its own thing but they are
both encompassed within the unhappy
consciousness because the unhappy
consciousness is what is conscious of
both of them and through both of them so
it says it is the unity the two takes
them to be not the same but opposites it
places them in opposition one of them is
simple not changeable it takes to be the
exception being the other of the protein
comes from the sky Proteus who had
changed into a whole bunch of different
things protein and changeable are really
the same thing it takes to be the UH
nacelle now the question is where does
the unhappy consciousness identify
itself it is both of these right and it
also is the unity or relation between
the two of them
but how would identifies itself and the
early stages and throughout most of this
this session is going to be on this side
with the empirical conscious
the changeable consciousness what well
in part because it doesn't yet have a
grasp on the essential and this is the
part that is seeking out the grasp on
the essential through some sort of
relation by having consciousness on the
unchangeable being so its own you can
say that the unhappy consciousness is
own understanding of this aspect of
itself is coming through the relation
between this part of itself to this part
of itself or the way this part of itself
grasp this part of itself that's what
the unhappy consciousness identifies
itself with the changeable on essential
contingent empirical consciousness as
unhappy consciousness identified myself
with this guy right here in 2015 with
you know this amount of beard wearing
this tie and so on and so forth right
why does it do that because this is the
way it can become conscious of the other
side of itself so he says the two are
for the unhappy consciousness alien to
each other so I should actually put
alien down here they are other they are
for all the use of these with these
words are ways of saying the same thing
friend they are they are you know they
don't they don't eat the same way they
don't they don't see things the same way
they have to go through sensitivity
training to not you know bruise each
other kids say right they are alien to
each other so this is all still within
the same person within the unhappy
consciousness he says because it is
itself the consciousness of this
contradiction that's another reason it
identifies itself of the changeable
consciousness the changeable
consciousness is the part that's kind of
screwed up raisin yeah I don't have it
all figured out I kind of wish I did but
some of this is confusing to me and the
confusion must be on my side mat over
here
this bit over here this is where the
answers lie and if I could just figure
out how to align myself my screwed up
self here with this wonderful eternal
essential unchanging you know add
whatever the divine attributes you want
being totally rational being everything
would make sense not like my totally
messed up contradictory only makes sense
for a little while life that I'm living
here starting to sound a little bit
familiar this is an important aspect of
the way in which many of us live for so
hey goes describing something here that
is in certain respects very essential if
you want to play with words so he says
although it tastes itself to be merely
the changeable and the unchangeable it's
for an alien being it is itself is
simply an unchangeable consciousness so
at the same time it's also grasping this
this but that some of the philosophers
will also be saying hey what about the
eternal in here what about the essential
in you right and the person down here
was it I don't really know that Hannity
demanded me I want to get to that so he
says it's aware that this consciousness
is its own essence although in such a
way that again it does not itself
hey the essence to be its own so this is
the uninhabited consciousness but a kind
of bar I kind of forget it the kind of
repression is taking place here that
keeps the unhappy consciousness from
being able to recognize that it is this
that's seeking on this other side in
itself so he says the attitude of the
science to both cannot therefore be one
of mutual indifference it cannot be
indifferent towards the unchangeable
rather it is itself directly both of
them and the relation of the two four is
a relation of essential being to the
unofficial so that the latter it has to
be set aside
but sense for it both our sense for it
older
lady central um contradictory it is
merely the contradictory movement in
which one an opposite does not come to
rest in its opposite but in it only
produces itself afresh as its opposite
when it is talking about there takes us
a little bit beyond the the problematic
as I've sketched it here as these two
interact with each other you notice that
we've got a relationship here our
consciousness of unchangeable being we
could also put the action seeking or
sacrifice or of attempting some sort of
connection with that which is essential
trying to leave itself behind connect up
with this what is the relation of the
essential being to the changeable
consciousness that's to be determined in
these later parts and ends it's back and
forth occurs we're going to see like I
said that that metaphor if you're trying
to reach for something and it's kind of
slippery and every time your fingers
grasp it it pushes itself a little bit
further away from from you and so you're
constantly chasing it that's what this
section gives the impression of
occurring through all of these different
ways by which human beings try to
connect themselves as the screw de
wildered on essential contingent
creatures that they are with something
that's bigger than themselves something
that makes sense but at a distance
something that is essential they keep
someone slipping out of grass and they
try this then they try this then they
move on to the next thing
interestingly enough that I'm going to
close by saying this this would not
necessarily have to be confined to just
the examples that Hegel is going to give
us as we go through the next paragraphs
and all the way to the end of this
section we could think of this occurring
in our own much more secular time in a
lot of other ways in which people try to
align themselves as the individual the
contingent with that which is
transcendent to them something that is
greater Hegel would say that the same
sort of dynamic of the end
the consciousness actually being all of
this at the same time would run
throughout this entire dynamic even if
it happens to be a non-religious a
secular way of doing
you